[Music]
my name's connor i'm an audiologist and
i'm expert in ears and today i'm going
to show you some earwax removal videos
there is liquidy soupy earwax
hard brick-like earwax and a particular
fungus called aspergillus niger earwax
is roughly
half skin a little bit of sebum which is
like a fatty oily substance and
something very special called
ceremonious secretion and ceremonious
glands secrete this kind of sweaty
liquid but it's got special molecules in
it which fight bacteria and try and keep
your ears safe you only ever need to
remove your earwax if it's bothering you
so if you have hearing loss or your ears
feeling full or uncomfortable or you
feel like there's an obvious blockage or
pressure that is abnormal and you should
go and see your doctor or audiologist or
practice nurse
[Music]
so this is something i would describe as
sort of the
soupy kind of quagmire type wax so you
can see actually that the debris has
sort of a texture to it like a wavy
texture and wavy lines in it
so that means that it's basically dead
skin that's sort of emulsified and it's
been treated essentially with fizzy
drops so sodium bicarb ear drops
probably and what that does is it makes
the debris liquefied and then slide
further down the ear canal and then
against the drum and that really does
cause quite a significant hearing loss
and feeling of discomfort
and what's happened here is that it's
kind of lost a little bit of its
structure which is quite difficult to
deal with because usually this type of
earwax is quite resistant to suction
the machine i'm using is called the
guardian pro jet basically you have a
tank is that hurting
and you have to fill that tank with
water which should be body temperature
about 37 degrees celsius and if it's too
hot or too cold then it will induce a
caloric effect which is where
basically you're heating or cooling the
fluid inside your inner ear and that
causes unpleasant vertigo which is like
a spinning dizziness like a drunk so you
put it the instrument in the ear canal
and you aim the water
at the roof of the ear canal so never
straight down the ear never aim it at
the eardrum and that's really when
accidents happen potentially perforation
of the eardrum so you aim it at the roof
of the ear canal and you sort of move it
like a sort of window washer and what
that does is it creates these sort of
vortices in the water and the gentle
sort of swelling effect sort of goes
into the ear and then just flushes
straight back out into the cup so it's
on the lowest setting and it's just kind
of squirting into the ear and we just
kind of leave it there and let the water
do the work you know most people find it
quite pleasant
[Music]
there's a little bit of debris or
slime left on the eardrum in that
situation
we probably go in with suction or maybe
continue the irrigation for you know for
a little bit longer if the patient can
tolerate it
you'll definitely want to have some
earwax left in there certainly not you
know up against the drum or anywhere
near the eardrum so a nice smearing or
slick of wax around the ear canal
will leave the patient protected against
the ear drying out protected against
infection itching
and obviously protection against foreign
bodies as well so that's a pretty nice
looking eardrum right there
when i first saw it i thought oh this
will be an easy job because you know the
wax is right there you can see it with
your naked eye so it's all good but then
as soon as i tapped on it with the probe
i thought right we're in for a heavy
ride here
the only way i can describe it is sort
of really like a brick it was
extremely tough and i started with the
suction but you know that was for all
intents and purposes pointless so in
this particular case i used something
called a porthole hook number six and
it's basically a very very very small
metal
right angle essentially the end is
perhaps a little pointy but it's not
needle sharp
this was extremely impacted
the reason it's dark much darker than
the previous case is because it's old
the older the wax is the darker it is
and that's because it oxidizes
i try to be very very gentle the
corthone hook is small enough such that
you can kind of get the hook round the
debris and sort of disturb it and sort
of leverage it out so really to put it
bluntly digging it out with a metal
instrument was was the only way really
you tend to find with this very hard
impacted sort of brick-like wax that you
can have pain as well when the patient
tries to self-treat with water-based
drops the plug will actually expand a
little bit so it'll absorb some of those
drops and then and then increase in size
temporarily
and if the plug is very deep in the ear
canal that can really really hurt and
cause a tremendous ache
the thing is you always have to go in
stages because if you shove the hook in
and then pull just in one go you can
cause barrow trauma which is basically
damaged by a pressure and that is
excruciatingly painful so you really
have to go very very carefully and tread
lightly
[Music]
what we can see here is that the sort of
yellow frills that are coming off the
main plug that that's just dead skin
when we see an impacted plug like this
there's usually uh you know sheets and
sheets of dead skin enveloping it sort
of like like a lasagna basically
and then the sort of darker brown bit
that's very very dense dry hard earwax
which has just formed over a long period
of time
it's impossible to say how old it is but
yeah it's it's definitely been in there
a while
the scientific name for it the
particular fungus is called aspergillus
niger the casual name for it is black
mold
aspergillus niger lives everywhere it
wouldn't be a shock for me if there was
some you know on your hand right now or
on your desk it's very common so the
likelihood is it was either in the ear
already or it was on a fingernail or
under a fingernail and the patient
scratched their ear
the reason it's got out of control is
anyone's guess
so for this i'm using a suction probe to
get the debris out of the ear and really
what i wanted to do was remove the bed
of the fungus the mycelium
and that's why you'll see this white
clothy material with the sort of goo
underneath it that's the very thick
well-developed rooting part of the
fungus on the eardrum
which is risky to some degree because
that's the kind of situation where you
can see a perforation
and usually what we tend to find is that
patients who have these very well
developed fungal infections is
more often than not because they've used
a lot of antibiotic ear drops
the reason why it's bad to use
antibiotic ear drops when you don't need
it is because you're disrupting the
natural balance of microorganisms in
your ear and if you kill off all the
good bacteria then the fungus has gone
hey this is a party and grown
unchallenged
i couldn't get all of the mycelium out
because it was sort of around the bend
and it was in a very very awkward
position but i achieved most of what i
wanted to which was to expose a nice
healthy eardrum and then of course that
paved the way for the anti-fungal drops
to do their job
this advice cannot be said enough if
your ear isn't bothering you don't poke
it don't prod it don't treat it with
anything don't put anything in it and
just leave it be most people will you
know maybe have an earwax blockage maybe
once or twice or three times in their
lives but it's it's not something that
you need to keep on top of regularly
because your ears are self-cleaning and
they will usually take care of
themselves
there's a single gene in the in the
human body that will determine
if your ear wax is wet or if it's dry
and crumbly so if you're from european
descent then you will have that wet
earwax gene or if you say from an asian
culture like japan for example then you
will have a drier crumbly flaky earwax
and that and that's due to the fact that
there is there is a gene which
determines which one you have